so on your podcast and your writing
you talk about some of the most
fascinating things that listen to you
talk about in terms of military conflict
is uh tactics instead of the details
of of combat
but allow me to stick on world war two
for a second
there's a particular aspect to that war
i don't know if you can speak to it
where twice the number of civilians died
in military personnel
so the soviet union especially
you know my uh my grandfather was a
machine gunner
on uh the in um ukraine
as the germans were marching towards
moscow there's this main
there's this important push in 1941
where they were trying to get before the
winter to uh to moscow
and what stalin was doing is he was
basically throwing bodies
at at uh to slow the attack
and what that meant is everybody
understood that you
your job was you have this heavy machine
guns
it's very it's almost unreasonable to be
able to be mobile in any kind of way
with them
so you're you're throwing at the front
and you're just non-stop
shooting and you know 95
plus percent of people are just dead
other soldiers are just dead
and then you just go back back and
you're trying to protect as many
civilians as you can throughout this
whole process but you don't
and so you have millions of civilians
that die along the way into this march
is there something you could say about
this complete perhaps it's naive of me
to say but
a war that lacks tactics
that lacks strategy
and is purely about just
no consideration of human life and just
throwing bodies
and bullets into a mix together where
millions die
and that in particular felt much less
like
conflict and much more like
torture or suffering
it didn't it didn't come off as torture
only that
interestingly enough as you probably
know my grandfather including everybody
else
volunteered they were proud to do this
they were proud to march to their death
for country for love of country
but the question on the civilian side
when when
more civilians die the military
personnel what do you make of that
it's awful and it's awful when
a soldier dies it's awful when a
civilian dies
it's awful when 10 civilians or 10
soldiers and it's
even more awful when millions and
millions of soldiers and civilians die
i think it's safe to say that the soviet
union was facing an existential threat
to their existence against the nazis
so to not fight
would be to die as well maybe die
death a few years later maybe die a
different way
but the choice was
die now trying or die later
on your knees and i think the choice was
pretty clear as far as the tactics go
i mean there is this is attrition
warfare that's what that is
we are going to keep you know you said
throwing bodies at the problem
that's attrition warfare and the soviet
union had a lot of bodies
more than the germans and when you fight
with attrition warfare
whoever has more men and material will
eventually win it's an awful
it's an awful way but
that's the that's that's what the
strategy was
you